what up reject nation we're here to
watch the boys season three episode four
today i want to thank everyone who's
been joining us on this journey and also
you know as always full length watch as
long as we sing them but the time go for
the boys available for our subah sexy
rejects
our patreon page with this being the
boys and the kind of content that it is
we've been getting them yellow dollar
bill signs limited or no ads essentially
what it means mainly means no ads so
with that in mind i want to thank helix
today for partnering up with us this
month supporting them helps support the
channel especially in a case like this
thanks to the folks at helix for
partnering up with us this month
especially because as you can tell
getting a new place need a new bed and
helix sleep makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to your
needs and conveniently shipped right to
your door now this may come as a shock
to you guys since i know i especially
look remarkably well rested and no one
ever comments about that but it's hard
enough getting enough sleep these days
and in the midst of exhaustion what
you're sleeping on can often be one of
the easiest things to overlook which is
unfortunate because it's actually a
pretty big part of your overall quality
of sleep luckily
really luckily helix makes picking out
and setting up a new mattress pretty
easy you just fill out a quick sleep
quiz from there helix will recommend
their best mattress tailored to your
needs i'm looking forward to it you
should be g because i've been trying out
the twilight lux mattress and i have
been loving it so far it's got great
support especially for your back which
is great for me because i've actually
had back surgery so that's something i
have to look out for it's super
supportive and above all else it's just
really comfortable that's good for you
i'm glad you got your bed first job and
from witnessing john do it the setup is
super straightforward just slide it out
of the box unwrap it cut open the
plastic and watch it inflate like me on
a bloated saturday plus they'll give you
a 100 night trial of your helix sleep
mattress a 10 year warranty with
financing options plus flexible payments
available so hit up our special link in
the description box to save yourself 200
on your helix sleep mattress plus get
yourself a couple free pillows and free
shipping within the united states of
america get some sleep people starting
now you look tired turn this off
it's solid gold starring marilyn monroe
with solid gold recording stars kim
carnes the oak ridge boy
the solid gold dancers and very special
guest
soldier boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
bars
the first flashback of mm's dad you're
on v temporary v
barely last 24 hours where'd you even
get it
one of them websites bonus for dice no
no no no
let's just give it a rest all right
it's over i'm fine wait wait did you do
the others now
no they do not i'm just gonna stay that
way
but all the boys should use we never go
after homeland or it is practically
federal policy no one is going after
anyone oh god just a gentle reminder of
who's in charge oh god just a reminder
that he can't get away with anything
he'll be perfectly safe
and zoe
especially zoe homelander might bark a
little but he won't bite
he's still afraid of me oh no
i would never let anything happen to you
or zoey
you know that right
yeah yes of course
do you know that can you i'm not even
fully confident about that
i'm after a particular bit of tech a
weapon you'll not be surprised to hear
and i thought you and your mates at the
kremlin might be old well you filmed a
couple of punters from the interior
ministry having a writing frolic under
your golden shower
[Laughter]
huge
sherry no
no that is all
i want
he said rock is him frenchy
go to the corner
whatever it takes this is
this is what it takes oh she seems so
empty
this has to work
it'll work
what'll work
um wowie
i'm sorry
how did you get in i have a key
yeah i got to keep an eye on my best
girl right
by the way you're a sound sleeper
starlight
oh don't look at you i'm kidding
[__] we got a hottest ship
don't you worry
this little love affair is strictly for
the cameras
although that's how me it may have
started out in that
quite spicy
you dick
[Laughter]
touch him or anyone he cares about
and i'll walk
and i'll take my approval points with me
women
what an [__]
[Laughter]
is
i hope that just disturbing how good
anthony starr is at that i'm just
brutalizing black people in trenton i
think vaught has a responsibility here
i just want to talk to him of course
social justice is so important around
here
no
no where are those people going
there's a protest on the street
[Music]
adrian where you going almost ready to
shoot
this is important
[Music]
oh jesus no
not this commercial they're doing it
they're going all out
no
no no no
[Music]
your regular kylie jenner a train have
you ever heard of something called
bcl red
you mean a weapon that can kill
homelander if butcher can find it
maybe i can buy but you're a second or
two to get a good shot
at the very least
i'll get a couple of licks in you guys
shouldn't talk you know you need to be
listening at any moment
only communicate through paper and burn
it
[Music]
that's it give me that b24
we just gotta do a little job for her
ain't nothing just some like lolliga who
got into bad books no definitely not for
nina well that's a good job then in
there
because you're not the one doing it
she is
oh
i'm not your [__] gun
that is exactly what you are
i'll tell you what to do
and you [__] do it i would never
throw in chemicals how he's been acting
lately he's invincible there might be a
way okay it's safer if you don't know
how
but
we need your help
there's me
there's maeve we probably need no don't
name anybody i'm so sorry alex i didn't
want to have to ask you this but
i don't know where else to go welcome to
the seven alex i really want to trust
you man i don't trust him i don't trust
it i want to
seriously we have the best taco bowls
right here in the building bienvenidos
muchacho
yeah i don't really speak spanish sir
oh my god i thought you know since we
got some rebuilding to do in that demo
maybe we could bench him for a while
wait you want to bench him don't we need
more super heroes not less
i mean you share a lot of the same bass
as blue hawk can you really afford to
look soft on crime
oh my god it's
actually
correct deep
good job
there's your answer good job
victoria newman is doing a press
conference tonight it's about you
and you're just finding out about it now
i'm sure it's a nothing burger
hey come here for a sec oh no no no no
no is your idiot brain getting [__] by
stupid
my idiot brain is not getting [__] by
stupids yeah go and do your only job and
find out what the [__] is going on
ashley
oh
don't kill ashley please don't kill that
she's trying her best to be mad on
stillwell
how about i tell homelander who really
leaked all that nazi [__] on storm but i
tell him you fished the flight 37 video
out in the atlantic and gave it to maeve
why come on look at me bro
right in the gills
you punch me yeah [__]
yep i was gonna say idiots
stay there and rest those useless
[__] lights
oh
man i'm actually feeling like really bad
for rachel i know here we
go homeland is gonna back him over me
after everything that i've done for that
man i hate one little speed bump now
i'm [__] garbage
don't don't don't say do that please
don't
what if oh
[__]
we could do something about it
what do you have in mind
oh man i'm so sweet so right here with
squeals just
i i fired that gun oh no no no no super
strength
or regular heel problems super balance
she's a soup
he'll break your head
these are
contraband
there's absolutely some contraband
homeland
i'll help that with my helix mattress
please tell me they actually market
those
oh my god oh
my god
these chemical fights are so brutal
[Music]
cut the tip
[Laughter]
[Music]
the
russian dildo massacre
no
what's in the head
she can heal can't you yeah yeah she is
still there
[Music]
don't do it don't snap she was just
trying her best man
just go give me go just go
oh she doesn't want to be this person
anymore only the bush can go from a
violent dildo fight
yeah
character beat
homelander
has bravely come forward as a
whistleblower and provided evidence of
crimes committed within bought by ceo
stan edgar oh my god oh
well
blackmail perjury and obstruction of
justice against mr edgar
holy god
oh my god that is so terrifying this is
not good
something i should have done a long time
ago this is a superhero company
always has been belongs to us not him
so i set things straight
it got to the kid right oh damn it's a
new day people
it's the dawn of a seven
oh man
oh he gave the knot oh my god hey
tristan
this is crazy this is crazy
i did not see this coming at all no
so nervous it's like the script was
written by a room full of chapped ass
monkeys in my right it's so bad i wrote
it
is your idiot brain getting [__] by
stupid oh my god what if i said
yes
then i would have to punish you
[Music]
i know i knew it
man trap it on
my idiot brain is getting [__] by
stupid man
maybe it's time we leave
and mmd need us so we do this job
and then where do you want to go
um
spit off
half it be like before midnight with the
two of them yeah we're going to control
the whole company right now yeah yeah
how do you think i found out you were
one of us
this isn't his this is someone else's
it's his
no huh
you're his weapon
that's what they do they have to do that
to us
they have to because they know
deep down when they lie away do you have
it or not
as promised the third homelander dildo
contingency
in case things go us over to
oh now you're really depending on i want
to try something here we go hmm [__]
it's poison huey led like you don't want
no part of it well you mean like a loser
no [__] up don't read comments man your
entire life is imploding and it's as if
you're reading [__] john grisham
god
i am curious
what did you give her a little respect
stan
something you should have given me
what good would that do
where would it even go
almost gaping pit of insecurity you call
the soul oh my god my dude
no one left to stand up to you you'll
come to sorely regret that because
there's no one left to cover for you
either the world will recognize you
for the pitiful disappointment you are
damn you're cutting are you trying to
get yourself killed you are simply
bad product
damn
you know when i was little
he did the same thing to me
and i'm all right we have to okay
god
oh no no no no no no no no
no
oh
that check nina didn't do us no
a favors
compound
russian military compound below storm in
a bar half fresh
the original or the remake
iv [__]
[Laughter]
if he does he does
what is it
oh [__] are we getting it oh he's frozen
in there dude
this is the captain america tube what
does he see
he says his name is jamie
hi
are you okay don't [__] with it just
leave him alone
oh
jimmy no seriously frenchy stop it
[__]
i told you not to [__] with him god damn
it
oh my god oh no
wow
laser them
time to expose yourself man
canary
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
oh
[Music]
i'm sorry
all right
oh
this season is wild they didn't give it
to him the thieving gate must have
broken them a case and nick did
let's just find this thing get the [__]
out of here all right
you're better than this kid
butcher
i'm not surprised
absolutely you
all right ruiz is so exceptionally
disappointing
here we need zone canary now
oh my god come on open it
slam i forgot all about this
oh man
mmm's definitely taking the v24 now
oh no
man he's been there for decades
it's okay
[Music]
whoa
oh no you're somebody 24. gosh frenchy
fresh gosh give me some fresh scars open
your eyes open your eyes oh dude
god it's all drugged up i must have done
something to him
what'd you think ain't no team for me to
hold together no more uncle you made
sure that come on come on give me go
hold her head up frenzy
open your eyes
that was really
uh that's not fun at all
no
i was twisted that's the thing about me
starlight if i promise something i
deliver now that
is the view of a lifetime
alex
oh my god what the [__]
[__] psycho
stop it you know how that ends ugh this
is your fault as much as it is mine
what adrien told me about youtube
exactly what i was worried about
that's exactly what i was worried about
from here on out
there is only my dutiful loving main
squeeze starlight if you so much as
[__] blink the wrong way then that
my love
will be
this huey
is so dark
god yeah
wow man
this
wow or are they like halfway through the
season and it's the the most menacing
season that that they've ever done is
like so
tense and taunts
i was ripping it's the most this is the
most ted season i think they've done
like yeah they're just like
truly just
twisted and
the way they let these dramatic dark
scenes play out just like the so many as
the episodes were
usually trying to like interspice the
fun and everything but most of so much
of this especially this one was just
like truly uncomfortable unsettling for
what what our characters are all
becoming and experiencing you know it's
always had that quality but especially
this time around it's it's menacing is
the work that keeps coming to mind for
what everyone's going through oh yeah
well because before i mean there's
always been obviously you know it really
involved character journeys for all the
boys and whatnot but it feels like
especially for for them and for
everybody this season is really like the
the desperation and the toll that takes
on your soul you know and everyone's
soul seems like it is going through a
big nasty change right now yeah
it's harsh yeah
that was fun
it's like diabolical sounds like more of
like a fun thing to say like a fun
twisted way and this is
this is like watching a dark drama a lot
of the time you know
yeah
yeah probably it's
bleak and menacing yeah that's what this
really feels like oh i get a lot i love
it
like to see like huey's arm out the
window like kimiko
dying in the back of the van and all
butcher and and like you're seeing what
the v24 effects have on it the drug of
it where
you know huey's just
enamored with his own like abilities
and it's just so
unaffected by everyone's judgment and
it's lost in it they've got their friend
dying in the back yeah and butcher is is
just like huh soldier
nope no [__] giving about chemical yeah
and
yeah it's just the way these scenes play
up it it takes its time a little bit
more and you really get to sit in the
darkness
this isn't a fun i don't associate this
one as being a that was fun of the
season it's it's always entertaining but
yeah goddamn this is like a drama now
yeah tons of fun bits and they're still
really good at flipping the tone around
and giving you something like the fight
with all the sex toys but then even
especially in this episode i started to
notice because it happens in the a train
bit with the commercial too they're
really great at
doing
one kind of scene and then leaving a
little coda moment on that scene like a
lingering camera or a little expression
that changes the tone in a
character-oriented way for the entire
scene we just saw and the progress
beyond it like it's
it's really masterful i think the way
they're able to jump
between the tones because the satire
runs from really goofy funny satire to
just the pitches blackest
most kind of soul-crunching satire it's
like
the most
the way they those lingering shots
you're talking about that this this
seems to have the most contemplative
quality with almost every single
character yeah
and then with home land which is
not unleashed in the sense like he's
just like lasering the world to death
right now but unleashed in a way of he
has
he he he's just he is himself now yeah
he's taking full control and he is not
hiding yeah yeah under any pretense and
to be in the power seat my god
that was very satisfying though that one
moment of actual satisfaction with stan
edgar still somehow
being able to tell him off in a way that
you can tell
does not make homelander feel good
yeah you know well it's like the because
now the more power that homelander gets
the further he's going
to descend and expose himself and he's
not going to be able to
hide like the less he hides the worse
it's going to get for him because he
still tries to maintain
public image because he seeks his main
thing as being validated by the public
and me being approved of um
and every and he's gonna that can slip
through the cracks for him easily by his
own behavior and then you know i
completely
forgot that oh yeah
soldier boy supposed to come back to
this show yeah and it wasn't until we
saw the tank and i was like that's right
soldier boy he's supposed to cut like
it's been so
such so much of the hype
for this season has been
you know soldier boy jensen ecclestone
especially if you're a supernatural fan
like we're only 10 seasons into the show
so far only 10. but you know what i mean
like you know the show's over so man
we're 10 episodes into the seas into
that so we've been excited for soldier
boy to come back for her for denzel
mackel to come and eric crippy and all
that
um but the show's so effective in
everything it's doing in it and as as
much as they're
moving things along quick like it's
escalating so fast and things are
descending
like a collapse is happening so fast too
it doesn't feel rushed at all no
it's just
cutting through all the [__] like
really not that the other seasons i've
ever felt like come on speed it up it's
just they're going from a to z like way
faster well yeah and every time they
give you some reason to feel a little
safe or secure they know well enough to
go no no what's the worst thing that
could happen that could really catapult
the story let's let's undermine the
sense of security we just gave you by
giving you an even more shocking
development like that thing where she's
given the speech and she turns it on
stan edgar and all that stuff that's
shocking yeah
like they're really coming off no no no
yeah because they're really going to
make you go like oh man the speech is
going down what the hell's homeland
you're going to do and then yeah they
pull the rug out from under you and it's
it's great because it it makes you tense
in the moment because now your heart's
beating but then you also know oh no
this is only going to get so much worse
yes and i can already see homelanders
gears turning of how his plan is working
and all that stuff yeah they're like
they're really good
like you said not wasting time but i
think it's more than that it's like
really embracing the
sort of catapult that really
not
not drawing things out can can do like
if you really set us up to expect okay
like i'm still enjoying this i'll be
happy if by the next episode this
develops and then they go ahead and do
it in this one you know yeah and i think
that's a great way to keep the story
feeling really alive and exciting and
and and getting you caught up in things
to the point where you're not wondering
about the other plot line or that plot
you're just here in the moment every
moment and i've been so used to kimiko
being a series regular character
that uh i was i
don't even
usually what i'm getting at is usually
in a show
when a character is going through this
like
transition oh yay we're gonna finally
flee and escape
oh my god that's usually the sign that
they're probably gonna die
nine times out of ten and my mind didn't
even go there that my mind didn't even
possibly think oh they're probably going
to kill her off
yeah i was just like i don't want them
to leave not that
we don't know if she's going to live or
die we don't know
uh however i
i mean i guess i just don't know she's
going to live or die i know that's a
good place to be in and too because yeah
it it at least subverts that cliche and
yeah in those moments where they're
talking about actually leaving you are
like i would be sad for them to leave
the show but also i want them to leave
and be happy and have lives together and
so yeah you get so wrapped up in that
and then when she's dying you feel the
actual peril and
and they're good at casting
again the focus around and making it
illustrate something like you pointed
out about huey and butcher in that
situation and what's happening to the
team and so like there's a lot going on
surrounding just the threat upon her
life and sustainability and i think
that's really cool because and also too
not having read a bunch of the source
material to know what the plot is there
with her
yeah i feel like they could go either
way and this is a show that establishes
that anything could happen and they
might you know she might survive but it
might not be exactly what we expect it
might not be a full return to recover uh
to full recovery or it might not be a
full return to being able to heal or
something like that you know well it
seems like the what the russians have
been doing yeah is
building
soldier boy
that's like kind of crazy like they took
in the ultimate american soldier and
they were trying to either i don't know
take dna from him
to build their own weapon or morph him
into a weapon himself
because that blast so powerful yes that
whatever did damaged her so badly that
she can't even heal from it now
i feel like she'll live i feel like the
cliffhanger is intentionally designed to
get you to come back next week so i feel
like
um but yeah also the effect of what's
happening to the other characters too
is what it's really leaning in on as
well sorry what do you want to say no
yeah it made me wonder if what they're
working on is something where it his
power
probably diminishes and perhaps uh you
know
neutralizes the actual super abilities
of whoever is on the receiving end of it
maybe like maybe that's part of it yeah
yeah um because i think the action space
chemical doesn't such an excellent job
and i hate to see them go and what what
i think this show has done remarkably
well every single season backed with the
performances by carl urban
is
the writing of butcher because they do
such an excellent job
at
they do push the character to the point
where you're like god you're an [__]
you know not they they'll they'll really
push it to the point of
he is he is
he's not a nice person like he's not a
good person to the point
where like he's our protagonist he's
right here like every season has its
moments you're like he's our
it's not the tony stark thing we're like
yeah he he has the front of an [__]
but you know he's good
yeah because a lot because this show
teeters between those shades so if he's
got the front of an [__] but we know
he's a really nice that he has a big
heart underneath
to oh he's actually being sensitive
vulnerable depending on his relationship
uh of who he's interacting with mm he
tends to be softer too you know
tends to bark orders that frenchy kind
of gives a lot of [__] to huey well but
i like what they've done with this
season is recognize the fact that
they had that whole thing in season two
about huey as your canary and now
they've leaned into that with their
relationship
is he can be more sensitive to to that
projection that butcher has of him as
younger brother i i really appreciate
that
and uh
like the way he is with the team in this
episode just how cold he is
how immensely cold he is
yet he reveals why he is that way
with mm um
i think that
that pushing this to the point of yeah
how do you say a team like this how do
you band together when
like it's just such a mess internally
first i think that's what this show is
doing so well as they create the turmoil
within first before all the external
stuff goes like bananas
when a lot of the external stuff is
already going bananas but you're
watching everyone deteriorate
and i love it because i love breaking
point [__] so much and everyone's
reaching breaking point it's feeling so
hopeless and like i keep wondering how's
soldier boy going to factor in
to
the preceding stuff with everything with
homeland or what's that going to create
you know i have no idea what direction
that's ultimately gonna
gonna go down but even they haven't been
going with a train uh like that first i
fir obviously was like don't tell this
guy he's gonna snitch he's gonna stitch
stupid super sonic he's going to snitch
but then they had that one little look
when uh after that whole thing with
victoria newman
of atrium like oh like i guess they're
trying this on their side like god damn
it you know i'm really curious about
that because that all happened off
screen so i'm sitting here going is was
a train basically reading the situation
well homelander is alpha so i got to go
back and appease him
or is it some kind of thing where
homelander like really intimidated it or
caught him and got it out of him uh
i mean i feel like a train is the type
to
do that based off of his character from
the past couple seasons
uh he
he would he's terrified of homelander
especially now that homelander is
top dog ultimate like once and for all
now at baud
it's like the the guy who created him is
gone from last season
stan edgar's gone madeline's gone
everyone's gone it's it's just
homelander now at the top
and the whole thing about we're a
pharmaceutical company not a superhero
company so for him to have that line
going we're a superhero company what was
happening yeah you know like completely
um changing
the
like giving in to what the facade is and
trying to make that the reality at least
sort of you know what i mean because
they're really not heroes after all
so yeah uh
i i love i i like how they've been
handling all that situation with
homelander
and
what they've been doing with victoria
newman especially is really interesting
because
i thought they'd be going down a path of
she's bad
you know corrupt and yeah
and homelander in a political suit
yeah yeah yeah like oh
she has the liberal guys yeah
and uh while she is definitely you know
like a little corrupt and not little but
yeah she she has her own agenda she's
playing for she is the the weapon for
stan all these years
you know she has to do
she's an assassin
and she has been taking orders from stan
edgar
i was enjoying watching that
relationship so i wanted to feel a
little bit more of that if there's
anything i kind of wish we got a little
bit more of was maybe just another
episode before that whole thing happened
with stan edgar um
being stripped because
i found that really compelling that
relationship victoria newman and stagger
have where it could feel because you see
that look that victoria has when
stan ecker's like why'd you do this and
she tells him uh something along the
lines of like you were never looking
after me you're always looking out for
yourself but she still feels like
conflicted and heartbroken like that was
still dead to her
you know yeah well i think there was an
element i don't remember exactly what
the line was but at the moment i also
took it as sort of a thing of like i'm a
you're always looking out for and trying
to protect me so in a way i'm going to
try and do the same thing for you
well she also said she's doing that for
zoey yeah her kid
and
like she's so scared that she's
it's different with like these these
parents who give their kids compound v
wanted a profit and
she seems like she's giving her a good
compound b to keep her safe just yeah
it's like the last insurance policy
i wonder what she's going to do
you know something is going to happen
her and ryan are going to become
boyfriend and girlfriend that's the play
there you go
young love with
insurmountable power we still have ryan
to come back into the fold yeah and i
mean last time we saw him he was pissed
so yeah
this is a this is like a a wild season
in a very different way yeah it's like
the way this season started with like
the crazy violent death of the
you know the jumping and the the penis
human sounding and that that scene was
just like okay this is going to be like
that balls the wall literally falls the
wall like
craziness of just nonstop violence and
maybe it'll have episodes like that but
the way they've handled crazy is in a
way that's more internal now
and more
the turmoil is so
strong and i really respect the show for
doing it because usually it's like we
gotta up the ante but only go i mean
that usually just means go more violent
go more sexual they have hero guys
coming up they're gonna have more
violence but they're i feel like they're
really earning their way to that crazy
build-up
you know well yeah because it
they're good at like even the scene with
all the sex toys it's like so outrageous
but it's set up in a way where it's just
like yeah that's the weapons available
at this moment so they're good at taking
the ridiculousness and motivating it by
various means that blend into the scene
so it's clear that they're not just
trying to set up for this kooky action
idea that we had because we want to be
so edgy
like yeah everything really feels like
it's part of this absurd demented world
and i like what they're doing with
ashley as well because
she's constantly trying to be like
madeline stillwell but she's never gonna
quite get there where madeleine stilwell
would usually
hide her fear
you know she wears her fear and answers
yes sir you know like she doesn't even
try to be boss
yeah and until she gets to that next she
she does to the people she absolutely
knows are below her and that's about it
you know and you can tell that she gets
off on that power dynamic
well guys another solid episode of the
boys uh i'm loving this season a lot i'm
really really loving and they're doing
it's diff so different
it's like the same but very different
yeah
yeah um
and man uh aaron moriarty i think is her
name oh yes
wonderful wonderful performance doesn't
get enough credit i think for her really
like brilliant acting
um everyone everyone's so great
everyone's like phenomenal like shouts
out to like everyone
they're all
uh subscribe click that bell thank you
to helix for sponsoring this video and
last but not least to send this
christmas swim off i chose you this day
because if there's anybody at patreon
who i'm thinking like i want to see
you're the best guy all right that's all
we talk about in your shout outs is just
how charitable and how noble and how
good of a guy you are well i want to see
if that holds up in the world of the
boys like if you were put in this world
with homelander and vaught and storm
front in the deep and all these [__]
would you be able to maintain
your we we good we good we set up is
this are we rolling okay would you be
able to maintain your spirit and your
good
nature in the world it doesn't seem like
look at huey all right look at him he's
already caving in he's going back to the
old ways would you chris wham-off be
able to be as jesus godly as you are
i think so buddy because you have the
best heart you have the best soul you
have the best smile and you have the
brightest eyes and i hope that one day
we get to meet and we get to just share
in a brotherly hug
chris all right you know this this shot
is looking good dude this is a great
cinematography
display
uh
demo right now but anyway chris
look
i really hope that you are doing well
and that you are bringing this to the
studio okay back to one
[Music]